pour m
[Musique]
colosse festif et rassembleur le
spectacle serge fiori seul ensemble et
tout ça et bien plus
[Musique]
pour installer l'univers musical de
serge fiori les premières minutes sont
plus poétique acrobatique
des envolées musicales incarné est un
fin dosage entre l'esprit des années 70
c'est l'époque actuelle assure une
fluidité entre les numéros
l'orchestration moderniser des chansons
par serge fiori avec l'aide de jean
cormier est grandiose
oh
en plus d'une vingtaine d'artistes sur
celle serge fiori cigarette au bec ni
faire son tour en projection et en voix
hors champ
[Musique]
c'est dans la deuxième partie que les
prouesses les plus impressionnantes
s'enchaînent funambule
planche coréenne
[Musique]
et contorsionnistes temps cette fois
sous à la fin le public déjà conquis à
claudie à tout vent
ouais capable de dormir ce soir
maintenant c'est mal à l'aise
[Musique]
et cette musique retravailler comme on
pensait d'eux des membres d'harmonium ça
enlève rien à ce qui a été fait mais au
contraire ça fait voyager le soin
apporté à la musique le respect est là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
jo
c'est l'ensemble est une communion
autour de l'amour de la musique qui nous
donne sans aucun doute le goût de
chanter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ici julie jasmin boudreau radio canada
montréal